what the [ __ ] is this to barricade to
listen and the other the [ __ ] is that
[ __ ] I am here at flood wall Street
with my good friend Ron Bailey we're
gonna chat a little bit about what's
going on we're expecting a few speakers
today just yesterday near Central Park
in Midtown we had a 300 thousand odd
persons strong marks for climate change
I believe you were there yesterday as
well what did you see there what are
folks getting right about the climate
crisis
and what are they getting wrong right
well there is a problem with global
warming it needs to be addressed
sometime and it's in this particular
century the question is one of the right
policies to do that and very often I
find that some of the policies are
somewhat kind of productive for example
again I'm not in favor of either nuclear
or subsidies or solar subsidies or oil
subsidies or any subsidies but the
problem is is that they've taken like
nuclear power off the table why would
you do that because it is a low-carbon
technology and no less a person than Jim
Hansen who is the first climatologist to
warn Congress about the problems of
global warming back in 1988 says you
have to use nuclear power that's the
only way to supply energy and so you
find a bunch of people who are against
that I think that that's
counterproductive what is the status of
climate science is there really a
scientific consensus and if so how rigid
is that consensus about what we're
facing there is a scientific consensus
among the climatological community that
human additions to greenhouse gases are
increasing the average temperature of
the globe there is absolutely consistent
question is is what's the rate going to
be how long do we have before things
become catastrophic and there's a lot of
consensus about that the more
interesting features of actual climate
history at the moment is and it's a deep
puzzle to a lot of climatologists is
that there has been a pause in the
increase of temperatures over the last
17 years carbon dioxide emissions have
increased by about 25 percent over the
last 17 years and the temperature on a
planet has essentially been flat as an
average over that period of time it's
been flattened at a high level but it's
still been flat and hasn't been
increasing and the climate models simply
did not predict this and and to this day
cannot account for that many
climatologist think though that the
pause will end sometime in the next
decade or so
and that the temperatures will start
going up much more rapidly that remains
to be seen Ron I know Naomi Klein is one
of the headline speakers today and she
recently wrote a book about the
environment and global warming and
ending capitalism or something like that
could you talk to me a little bit about
the book I know you recently wrote a
review of it for a reason right the book
is called this changes everything and
the idea is is that climate change is
finally going to do capitalism in what's
interesting about it of course is
Naomi's been an activist against
capitalism a very long time her first
book was no logo and Ricci argued that
globalization would do capitalism in her
next book was the Shock Doctrine and she
argued at that book that the financial
crisis would do capitalism in well
finally she's decided climate change is
going to do it it's kind of interesting
because you might think about how you
might handle climate change would
involve kind of market mechanisms
perhaps a carbon tax working on new
innovations like better sort of solar
panels I
and she seems to dismiss that she thinks
that everything should be more or less
oddly top-down and decentralized at the
same time and it's kind of a little bit
incoherent one of the things I find most
interesting when she talks about
transforming the world's energy system
completely renewable by 2030 she doesn't
tell people how much it's been a cost
and it may be something that we have to
pay but she doesn't say how much it's
going to cost and at least one of those
studies she cites it's going to be a
hundred trillion dollars which would be
something like 11 percent of the world's
GDP every year between now and then and
it would be interesting for people to
know that well Ron thanks so much for
chatting for recent TV I'm Camille
fossil